so the root of the word passion actually
means to suffer and so the implication
is to is how much are you willing to
suffer on behalf of X that's what it
means to say I'm passionate about X
that's where the whole idea of The
Passion of the Christ comes from the
passion is the willingness to suffer you
know for the sins of humanity
so as an analogy let's say you know for
what it means to follow something let's
say I'm let's say my dog is running away
from me and I'm chasing after my dog so
I can be said to be following my dog and
pursuing my dog and he's running around
corners and I'm going around the corners
everywhere he goes I'm going and then
there's one point where my dog jumps
over a fence and I get to the fence and
I say well I don't want to ruin my
t-shirt I'm not jumping over that fence
am i following my dog am i pursuing my
dog
no I'm I was following my dog but I'm
following my obstacle now I'm pursuing
my obstacle right because because I
stopped chasing after the thing right
and so a lot of great example then yeah
a lot of times people people are you
know like in order to follow your
fashion in order to follow your passion
what we would say about that follow your
fashion but in order for me to follow my
dog in this instance what do I have to
do I have to go beyond that obstacle
right I have to hop over the gate and go
beyond it if I'm not willing to do that
then I'm not a passionate person I'm not
pursuing that so a lot of times we say
well I want to follow my passion and we
equate that to mean we equate that with
meaning I want to do what feel cos feels
good all the time but following your
passion means pursuing what you believe
in even past the point of your obstacle
another thing you talked about making
sure things line up with your values one
of the negative consequences of placing
so much emphasis on following your
passion is that there are a lot of
people who now buy into this notion that
they are some kind of sellout for not
doing something that they love so you
have people that are plumbers and
electricians they're making a good
living they're providing for their
family they've been feeling pretty proud
they don't particularly love what they
do but they're you know they're they're
content they're doing well they're
working hard
and now they're thinking to themselves
well is this a bad thing should I be
feeling more excited at my job and while
I think it's totally legit to say I want
to figure out a way to translate what
excites me into an income there's
something dangerous about getting into a
space where you're now feeling guilty
because you don't think you're an
example to the world of what it means to
follow your passion so just make sure
that as you're trying to follow your
passion you're following your passion
not the passion you think you ought to
have in order to live a life that's
impressive to other people yeah man no I
totally agree like to any plumber or
electrician anyone out there that's got
you know this job that maybe isn't like
sexy and exciting and it's not you know
changing the world but if someone is in
that role and like they are that you
know for all intents and purposes
they're happy or they feel like they're
living a meaningful life like that's
everyone everyone who's asking these
questions that's all they want
yeah they just want to find something
where they can come home put their head
in their pillow go to sleep and say you
know what like yeah I'm not I'm not
changing the world I'm not making my
dent in the universe yeah but I feel
really good and left and that's that's
okay but you're right man like judging
or not judging but feeling judged and
starting to look at how other people
pursue their career I don't know why I'm
having so much trouble talking today but
it can really it can really hurt or yeah
our pursuit I think that that I have
news for those people as well
um I make a living as a writer and it is
not exciting 95% of the time in fact
it's only exciting because yeah the old
quote you know writers don't like
writing they like having written and and
it's so true like I there I get to a
point where I all of a sudden I do feel
really good or I feel accomplished but I
imagine it's the same way that like when
I used to wash dishes way I would feel
really accomplished by like somehow I we
got through the crazy dinner rush and
all of a sudden like I don't know how we
cleared all those dishes and 45 minutes
but we did it I felt accomplished
afterward it's the same thing with
writing I think it's the same thing with
any profession most of what you do most
of the time
is not going to be exciting and that's
okay in fact if it's always exciting
it's probably an indicator that it's too
comfortable and those obstacles create
the discomfort you need to grow yeah I
love that so instead of following your
passion also experiment with the concept
of flirting with your passion so as an
example with your passion or with your
passion so as an example let's say some
young guy comes in here and he says hey
guys I'm you know I'm successful I got a
good job but I want to be married I want
to have a life and I want to start a
family what are some tips on finding a
good wife and then we started talking to
him saying stuff like hey man you know
don't worry about that too much just get
out there and meet people live your life
do things you're interested in
try to make friends that kind of feels
like a consolation prize when people
that are married are telling you that
right at least it felt like that for me
once a once appointment one time yeah I
felt like a constellation of price like
oh that's easy for you to say you
already have your wife right yeah but
there's something to be said about that
approach because that approach actually
protects you from something very
dangerous and that is it protects you
from going on a first date and being so
obsessed with the end result that you
say as you're getting to know that
person so where is this going
you know um you're never gonna get
anywhere with anyone if you talk about
marriage on the first date right you're
gonna freak them out and everything is
gonna go wrong
can't even talk about it on the second
date or the third day now I know
somebody's gonna be all over youtube
comments like well I actually love it
for large men yeah yeah but generally
speaking it's it sounds like a cop-out
it sounds like disappointing advice but
it works like magic it's actually how
things work in life that you start at
the level of not putting pressure on
your relationships by saying where this
is going and you say hey let's just have
coffee you know let's just have a
conversation let's see where this leads
and right if this is fun maybe we'll do
this a second time with no pressure for
anything else and that's how you got to
do with your curiosities and your
passions as well if you try too early to
force it into something that can
generate an income you won't learn very
interesting things about it that could
be a pivotal part of that process later
on yeah
you